as you all know Ramadan is coming to us
soon Ramadan is a month of forgiveness I
worship and a month from which a person
draws closer to his Lord and it was
narrated by the companions that some of
them they would supplicate to Allah six
months beforehand so that they would
reach the month of Ramadan by saying
Allah Ramadan Allah allow us to reach
the month of Ramadan and as you all know
Ramadan is a month of Good Deeds charity
prayer visiting the sick all of these
things are from the actions of Iman and
better ones Islam so let us prepare for
this blessed month and let us not forget
the mids appeal we need a new place the
community and the da is growing and
after Allah subhana T's permission we
are in need of your efforts and your
donations so let us not forget the true
investment the investment of the
afterlife and as you all know the
narration whoever builds house for Allah
for his worship a mosque then Allah will
build for him a house in Paradise who's
to say this can't be our last Ramadan so
let us work hard collectively in trying
to establish a mid and we ask Allah to
accept our good deeds and allow us to
reach the month of
[Music]
[Applause]
Ramadan
[Music]
Al
this is the second
session that we're
having here at
Mas in
Philadelphia as relates to the signs of
the hour and more specifically
theal
yesterday we began this topic and we
mentioned the mention of the Dalal and
the books of the scholars of the
salaf the 3D fourth fifth 6th and
seventh
century likewise we mentioned why was he
called the Dalal and
Al and likewise we mentioned some of his
description and likewise we mentioned
some of his
actions and today we will continue
with some of his
actions we will also mention some
issues uh that individuals may consider
to be a conflict or
misunderstanding
we will also
mention the fact the places that he
cannot
enter the places that he cannot
enter we will also
mention his
followers some of his
followers we will also mention by the
permission of
Allah what what an individual should do
to protect themsel from the
Dalal and we will close with a mention
of his destruction how will his affair
End by the permission of Allah Asel as
it relates to his
actions we mentioned yesterday and from
the last that we will mention because of
time because there's yesterday we we had
free reign because there was no lecture
after our lecture we had the last
lecture yesterday but today there's a
lecture after so we will summarize to
the best of our
ability it was mentioned in
sahkari in the on the authority of
Abu and like we did yesterday some of
these narrations if they're long we will
translate them directly to preserve time
Abu who mentioned that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said or Abu said one day the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam gave us a
long narration about the
Dal and that was an example of how the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
extensively sat with the sahabah and
warned them so Abu said the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam one day spoke
for a very long time about
the and from that which he said s.
wasam is that the Jal will
come and he will be forbidden to pass by
the mountains of
al-madina and if anyone has visited al-
Medina the mountain Medina is surrounded
by
mountains so if an individual passes
those mountains then they enter into the
city so he is not able to pass those
mountains because if he does so that
means he would enter into the City and
he is not allowed to enter into the city
as we see in this narration and the
coming
narrations so he sets up camp this is
Abu informing that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said so he
sets up camp outside of the area of
Medina and a man will approach
him and on that day this man would be
the best of the people meaning he's a
Believer this man is from the
Believers and he will say I testify that
you are the
Dalal who the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam has informed us about I testify
you are that individual you are that
man the Dalal would say to his audience
his
followers if I kill this man and then
bring him back to
life will you doubt me and they will
reply no they are his followers they are
the individuals that believe in
him and then the Dalal will kill this
man and then he will bring him back to
life and the man will say I swear by
Allah I recognize you even more
now I recognize you even more now
then the
Dalal would try to kill him again
because he has rejected him and this
time Allah does not allow the deal to
kill
him this time Allah doesn not allow the
Dalal to kill him and the scholars
mentioned that's an indication of his
ble there will come a time when the
Believers approach him or if if a
Believer approaches him he will not be
able to kill him a second time so Allah
proves to his people and his followers
that he is not Allah because remember he
claims to be Allah he claims to be our
Lord so that time he would not be able
to kill
him there's an
issue there's an issue this is one of
the issues that we would like to
discuss in
brief and that was one of the questions
yesterday someone asked me a question
are
these uh unprecedented
actions or
miraculous actions of the Dalal are
these
Illusions are these Illusions or is it a
reality him killing someone bringing
them back to life him ordering the sky
to rain ordering the crops to sprout is
it an illusion or is it a
reality
IM
IM in his and this is important that we
understand
this
IM
in he mentions this issue
and we're referring to this issue and
the ones we mentioned
yesterday mentions this and he
said there's a Hadith that some of the
scholars of the
salaf
used to support the fact that it's
Illusions and it's not a
reality that Hadith yesterday my dear
brothers and sisters was the Hadith of
Hu
and you possibly recall it where he said
he has paradise and he has hell and he
has Rivers you Brothers remember
that and one river is Paradise and the
other river is hell in that narration it
was mentioned based on a person's
perception it was mentioned based on
someone's
perception so Imam ha
IB C said some of the scholars of the
salaf felt that it's an
illusion and from them and this is why
we should know it
imaha and
ibam IM tahawi from from the great
Scholars of the salaf and I haam also
from the scholars of the salaf and
others they were of the opinion that
it's only
deception they were of the opinion that
that it is only
deception then he
mentions
then mentioned and then you have
individuals that totally deny all of
theth about the about
the from amongst the
J and the and
the the J and the
and
the they refuse all of the narrations
about
the and because of that you recall
yesterday that we began with mentioning
theal from the books of the Sala the
books of the books of toed and the likes
the reason one of the reasons why the
salaf put that in their books was to
refute the
J and to refute
the and to refute
the that was one of the reasons why they
put it in their books of because the the
and the they they refuse all of those
Hadith they refuse all of those
Hadith
then he
says
said he concluded by saying what is
Apparent from all of their narrations
about the Dalal is that those actions
are
reality and it is a test from Allah for
his
servants
so was from the the scholars that were
of the opinion and many
more he was from the scholars that were
of the opinion no these actions of the
Dalal unprecedented actions pointing at
the sky ordering the sky to rain
ordering the scrp the crops to sprout
killing an individual and bringing him
back alive those are actual actions that
he Allah gives him the ability to do as
a test for the cre
as a test for the
creation
and concluded by
saying this is not a
deception this is not a deception or an
illusion it is not
illusion it is a reality that Allah is
testing his
servants Z man during that
time he said so many people will be led
astray and others will be
guided those who will be led astray are
the people with doubt and those who have
faith will increase in their faith and
those who have faith they will increase
in their faith that was one of the
issues that we wanted to
discuss let's
continue from the
places from the places
that the Dalal would not be able to
enter is Mecca and
Medina is Mecca and al-
Medina it's reported in
Muslim on the authority
of that the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam said to the
sahabah when he was mentioning the story
of
tamim and this story by the
way before we mention the
part remember yesterday we
mentioned that one of the things that
the Believers amongst the
many but one of the things that the
Believers benefit from
the from the signs of the last day is
that it makes you firm in your belief
recall we mentioned that it makes an
individual firm in their
belief because when it
occurs the Believers realize this is
exactly what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam informed us just like
that individual in the Hadith of H that
goes up to the
Dalal right and the deal kills him and
then he brings him back alive he said
now I'm even more firm that you're the
so it increased him in in
firmness but in this Hadith of
fatim when the prophet theith in Muslim
the beginning of the Hadith when Tam and
other sahaba came and told the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam that the long
story that they went to a island and the
likes of that when the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam got on the
mimbar and began to speak about the
story of tamim the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said I am happy that
tamim came with this story because it
supports what I was always teaching you
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam showed the sahaba and expressed
his happiness that one of the companions
actually witnessed it and came back to
tell the story so in that in the
beginning of this Hadith the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said I'm
happy I'm amazed that tamim has come
with this narration because it supports
what I was always telling you so this is
an example of the S of the Prophet s
being happy because of the
story at any rate going back to what we
said that the Dalal would not be able to
enter Mecca and Medina in that Hadith
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said that
Tam when they met
the the spoke to them and what did the
say from what he
said he
said I
am and my time of appearing is
close my time of appearing is close
I will go throughout the earth now this
is theal himself speaking to the
companions that saw him he said I will
go throughout the Earth and there will
not be a village except that I will
enter it and I will do it in 40 days
then he
says
except Mecca and Medina he told them
except Mecca and
Medina then he said the
reason I cannot enter those
cities I'm forbidden from entering those
cities but then he expresses that he
tries he
says
he said every time I try to enter one of
those
cities I am approached by an
angel holding a sword in his hand he
prevents me from entering those
cities
every corner of those cities is guarded
by an Angel protecting it from me
entering that
City so that's one narration you also
have another narration reported in the
mus of IM Ahmed on the authority of
junad that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said I warn you of the
M the prophet said it twice I warn you
of the
M then the prophet said he is a man with
a blind
eye he will dwell throughout the Earth
for 40
days he will have with him a mountain of
bread or
food he will have
Rivers his authority will spread
throughout the Earth
then the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam
said he cannot enter four
masjids he cannot enter four
masjids then the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
said he cannot enter Al in
mea he cannot me enter
in
Palestine he cannot me enter a Masid in
t which is somewhere in the Middle East
around the area of Egypt and he cannot
enter the Masid in al- Medina The
Prophet's mid
s. so this narration mentions four mid
the previous narration mentioned two
cities the previous narration mentioned
two
cities you also have it reported in
bukari and
Muslim on the authority of ANB
Malik that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said there is no
land except that the theal will enter
that land except Mecca and
Medina then the prophet sallam gave
details that was not in the previous
narration he
said
then the prophet Sall wasallam said
about these two cities there is no
corner of these
cities except there are angels in
rows guarding these
cities except that there are angels and
Rose guarding these cities to the of
that Hadith so the Dalal cannot enter
Mecca or medina and those four mids like
we mentioned his
followers from the followers of the D
that have been mentioned in the
authentic Sun of the Prophet sallallah
alai wasam the
Jews and more specifically the Jews of
asbah and asbah is currently and
Iran and before we read the narration
yes you can search for it there are Jews
there's a there are more the population
afan the population of Iran more than
50% of them are
juice more than as of today more than
50% of Iranians are
Jews look at what the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said in the Hadith in
Muslim on the authority of ANB Malik
that the prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam
said the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said the Dalal will be F from
his followers will be followed by 70,000
Jews from asahan from Iran and they were
at
is a white cloak it's a white cloak that
they wear over their heads and they
still wear it till this day and they
still wear it to this day it has uh it's
a woven cloak that they wear over their
head especially when they're
praying so that's one group of his
followers the
Jews another group of his followers the
Turks and the
non-arabs it's reported in the of
iMed on the authority
ofak that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said that the Dalal will
appear the Dalal will appear in the
east from an area which is called
horasan andan is an area of of South
Russia you have those countries that are
in South Russia and from those countries
you have Iran north of Iran you have
this area then the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam says he would be
followed by
individuals their faces are like
Al beaten Shields flat faces and that's
that area that you have uh north of
Afghanistan south of Russia
you have that area individuals will be
following the
Dalal likewise another group of his
followers the
women it's reported in the mus of IM
Ahmed on the authority of
abdah that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam stood With His companion
one
day and he
said how wonderful Medina
is when the appears there will be an
angel at every
corner he will not enter this city so
the prophet sallam is in Medina and he's
speaking to the sahabah and he said this
is a wonderful City this is a wonderful
land every corner of this city has
Angels which are protecting it the Dalal
would not
enter while those angels are on
guard the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said while the angels are on
guard guard there will be three
earthquakes in
Medina there will be three earthquakes
in
Medina there will not be a
hypocrite a man or a woman a male
hypocrite or a female hypocrite who
dwells in Medina except when those
earthquakes take place they will leave
and join the
D they will leave and join the
Dalal then the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said and the majority or the Abundant of
people that will leave and join him are
the women are the
women and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said this is the the day of
purification purifying Medina so you
have Hypocrites that live in Medina and
dwell in Medina you have Hypocrites that
live and dwell in Medina so
theal and he knows that he can't enter
Medina but he will still try to go to
Medina and he's blocked so he waits on
the
outskirts he doesn't just
approach Medina and say oh I can't enter
so he goes back and goes to other places
no he
waits and it's
reported in the musn of IM Ahmed that he
actually hits the ground look at that
Subhan Allah it's reported in the mus of
IM Ahmed that he strikes the ground and
then the earthquakes the earthquakes
take place and the Hypocrites leave and
they join him they leave and they join
him the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said this is the day that Medina will
get rid of the bad people the bad
individuals individuals who have
hypocrisy individuals who love evil that
would be the day that they leave Al
Medina that would be the day that they
leave al-
Medina
is
mentioned
by in
his
mentions in and we'll summarize it
because it's
long he said the theal would
appear and by the way this is another
issue there was a narration that said
that the Jal would appear between Iraq
and
Syria and then you have the narration
that says the theal would appear in
asbah the
scholars reconcile between that by
saying he comes
out he comes out in the area between
Iraq and
Syria but he
begins his mission in the area of
asbah he begins his mission
in the area of
asbah in an area that is called Al
Y and that area is in
Iran IB kir said he is supported by
70,000
Jews and they have their
weapons and they have these
cloaks until this day they wear these
cloaks
ATA they wear these cloaks
then IB cath said he will be supported
by the
Turks he will be supported by the people
Froman then IB K said he will first
appear as a
king he will first appear as a
king then he will claim to be a
prophet then he will claim to be
a lord he would claim to be
Allah so ignorant people will believe in
him and follow
him and he will be
opposed by the individuals who Allah
Asel has
guided and the people of
certainty he will
continue to go throughout the Earth
Earth Bad Bad Country after
country Fort after Fort every
place every small or large Society every
village every city he will go
throughout he will not leave any
city except that he will walk through it
with his army and his
feet then IB K says except Mecca and
Medina Kath continues to say his time on
Earth is 40 days a day like a
year and a day like a
month and a day like a Friday like a
week that's what he means when he
says he means a week so one day is like
one day is like a
year one day is like a
month and one one day is like a week
then the rest of the days are normal
days what is that calculation says
it the calculation for it is one year
two months and a
half one year two months and a
half thenb
says
Allah has created many miraculous on
more or never unprecedented
actions so that he can guide the people
astray so that he can guide the people
astray to the end of what I C
mentioned
cutting through some of
it how does an individual protect thems
from
the how does an individual protect
himself from the deal it's mention
in on the authority
of that the prophet sallallahu alai or
she
said
said that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to supplicate in his
prayer the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to say in his prayer oh
Allah I seek refuge in you from the
punishment of the
grave and I seek refuge in you from the
FNA of the
m and I seek refuge in you from Life y
the trials and the tribulations of
life and I seek refuge in you from the
trials and the tribulations of death so
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
used to seek refuge in the Dalal and he
used to teach it to the
sahabah it's also mentioned in sah
Muslim on the authority of
Abu that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
said if one of you does t and this
informs you when you seek refuge in the
Dalal you do it at the end of the prayer
the prophet sallu alaihi wasallam said
if one of you
makes at the end of the
prayer let him seek refuge in Allah from
four oh
Allah oh Allah I seek refuge in you from
the punishment of the
grave and from the pun aan one oh Allah
I seek refuge in you from the punishment
of the
Hellfire and I seek refuge in you from
the punishment of the
grave and I seek refuge in you from the
FNA of living and
dying and I seek refuge in you from the
FNA of
Al and that's reported in sahim
Muslim and here the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
said I seek refuge in you from the
Hellfire which is an explanation of the
previous
narration so the prophet sallallahu Alam
you seek refuge in Allah from the
Hellfire and refuge in Allah from the
punishment of the grave and refuge in
Allah from living and dying the trials
of living and dying and refuge in Allah
from the fitna of the
it's furthermore reported in sah
Muslim on the authority of
Abbas he
said and it shows you how diligent the
prophet Muhammad sahu alai wasallam was
in teaching the
sahab
said
the prophet used to teach us this Dua
just like he used to teach us a s from
the
Quran and you could understand that how
the prophet Sall used to sit down with
the sahaba and teach them the Quran
review the Quran read the Quran correct
them he used to teach them this Dua the
same way he used to teach them this Dua
the same
way the prophet used to teach
them
oh Allah we seek refuge in you from the
punishment of the
Hellfire and the punishment of the
grave and the punish and the FNA of the
and the FNA of living and dying to the
end of that
Hadith to show you how the salaf view
this is mentioned IM
Muslim IM Muslim mentioned on the
authority of
binan one of the Sala and his one of his
teachers or the narrators of
Hadith that
tan and you find in the books of
Hadith IM
Muslim mentioned
that that t taught this Dua to his
son ba taught this Dua to his
son and his son
prayed after he
prayed said to his son did you say the
Dua that I taught you did you say the
Dua that I taught you his son said no he
said repeat your
prayer repeat your prayer yeah the
Sal was so careful to make sure they
teach it to the their family members and
to their children to their family
members and to their children that he
made his son repeat another example
inar it's mentioned
that the son
of who is uh one of the
Companions and one of
the is his son he said that s Our Father
used to teach it to us he used to teach
us this
Dua and he used to inform us that the
prophet taught it to
them and he ordered us to say it and he
ordered us to say it the same Dua oh
Allah I seek refuge in you from the
punishment of the Grave until the end of
the
Dua till the end of the
Dua as it relates to to seeking Refuge
it was mentioned by
IM in his book that we mentioned
yesterday IM has a book in what is it
called IM died
360 IM died
360 in his
book He
said
said chapter he gave it a chapter title
he said the
chapter the prophet seeking refuge in
Allah from
the and teaching it to his
umah and teaching it to his umah that's
the chapter title The Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam seeking Refuge from
the and teaching it to his
umah then then
[Music]
IM
IM in his book of he mentioned the
chapter
the chapter of the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam seeking refuge in Allah
from the and teaching it to his
umah and teaching it to his um then IM
mentioned several narrations where the
Prophet s wasam used
to then IM mentioned several narrations
with the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam used to teach it to his
um then then IM
said then he said this is the statement
of IM from
360 he
said and I will translate it directly he
said so it is incumbent
IM he said so it is
incumbent upon the Muslims to seek
refuge in Allah from the deal it is
refuge in Allah from the Dalal because
the prophet used to warn his umah from
him in many narrations and the prophet
described him for his umah so it is
incumbent notice he says it again so it
is incumbent upon the
Muslims to be cautious of him and to
seek refuge in Allah from him him and
the time that he appears in from him and
the time that he appears
in from him in the time that he appears
in because the time that he appears in
will be a very difficult time may Allah
protect us and you from him that's the
Dua that's the statement of IM and his
Dua another thing that protects a Muslim
from the to memor Miz verses from Surah
Alf to memorize verses from Surah Alf is
mentioned in sah
Muslim in the Hadith ofas
Sam that the prophet s said in the
Hadith so whoever meets the D let him
recite the opening verses of Surah
Alf let him recite the opening verses of
Surah Alf
is also mentioned in sah Muslim on the
authority of
Abu that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever memorizes 10
verses from the opening verses
of he will be protected from the he will
be protected from
the so that's another thing that protect
the Believers from the is memorizing
verses from
Al another thing is that a person no
matter what he stays away from him a
person no matter what he stays away from
him and my dear brothers and sisters
this is a FNA of this time the FNA of
this time
people following
influencers and I just got to see him
I know he's a liar but I just want to
see him
once that's today
influencers that people who are nobodies
can open an account on Twitter or
Facebook Instagram and do stupid stuffff
and in two weeks they have a million
followers two weeks a million followers
doing
nothing nothing I just got to see him
right the prophet sallah am says as is
reported
in the
immed in the of ab and others in
declared authentic
by that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said whoever hears about the
stay away from
him whoever hears about the Dalal stay
away from him for verily a
man for verily a man
will approach him and the prophet is
talking about a Believer will approach
him and before you know it the
individual follows him before you know
it the individual follows him and the
prophet
said because of his
doubts because of his doubts and recall
my brothers and sisters and there will
be an individual that approaches him and
disbelieves in him and we mentioned the
narration yesterday disbelieves he
disbelieves in him and the deal would
say what about if I bring your parents
back to
life what about if I bring your parents
back to life and then two shtin come one
in the form of his mother one comes in
the form of his father and say to him
you should believe in this man he is
God look at that FNA so the prophet
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
individual if you hear about him stay
away from him him if you hear about him
then stay away from
him
likewise another thing that saves a
person from theal and it's preceded to
live in one of two cities and they were
Mecca and Medina they were a mecah and
Medina because of the Hadith ofan bin
Hussein that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
aan the
Hadith the Hadith of Abu the Hadi of
abua where the Prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said there are angels at the
corners of these
cities there are angels at the corners
of these cities and likewise the Hadith
of ABI
bakar the Hadith
ofak that the prophet Al wasallam said
the would not be able to enter Al Medina
the would not be able to enter al-
Medina another thing that saves a person
from the
deal having knowledge of your
religion having knowledge of your
religion
and from
that is the previous
Hadith where the Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam the Hadith of Abdullah
Bin Omar in bukari and
Muslim and we mentioned it
yesterday where the Prophet sallallahu
alaih said to the sahabah I'm going to
say something I'm going to describe him
like no other Prophet has described him
then the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam
said you know that the Dalal is
blind and your lord is not so the
Prophet Sall said you
know the prophet sallam said you know
likewise in that same narration the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said you know that no one will see his
Lord until until he
dies right no one will see his Lord
until he dies so the prophet sallam said
you know twice to his sahaba which means
they have what they have knowledge
IMB in fat he
said this is an
indication that the is a liar claiming
to
be God claiming to be Allah he is a
liar but he's claiming to be
Allah because notice this this F
of IB ha and he's basing it off of that
narration where the Prophet said you
will not meet your L you will not see
your lord until you die remember that
you will not see your lord until you
die said this is proof that he's a liar
claiming to be
God
because the only time you can see Allah
is
when when you die
but the deal is going around Earth and
can people see him yes so when
individuals see him they should realize
you can't be God because I will not see
Allah until I die you get the point so
IB Haj is saying this is a proof that
he's a
liar and this makes the believer firm
because when you hear about him or you
see him you know that you haven't died
yet and in order for you to see Allah
you have to die so this is further proof
that he is a liar it's further proof
that he's a liar and further proof that
we have to have knowledge it was
mentioned by
IM in
his one of the books of the Sala and he
died
1188 talking about 300 years ago around
that time IM
said he said the chapter look notice
this book of AA he said the
chapter it is
befitting and incumbent to spread the
Hadith about theal to spread it to let
it be known amongst the people and under
that chapter IM sa says and we'll
translate it directly he said it is
incumbent upon all people of knowledge
to spread the narration about
the amongst their
children amongst their
women amongst the men notice he said
it's incumbent upon the people of
knowledge to
spread the narrations about the Dalal
amongst the
children amongst the women amongst the
men and then he
said that one of the Sala said
said even the people who teach the
children should teach the children about
the even the people who teach the
children and it's possible and this is a
f because you get some parents that said
no they're too young for that you get
some parents they say no they're too
young for
that it would scare them or the
likes so if you said they're too young
for
that is what about the fact that the
prophet used to teach it to to the
sahaba whether they were young or old
Anis IB Malik was he an old sahabi he
was young Abdullah IB Omar was he young
or old young Abdullah Abbas young or old
young these all young sahaba AA and
notice I said Abdullah Omar and he was
one of the narrators of the Hadi of she
was one of the narrators IB Abbas one of
the narrators Ali one of the narrators
and all of them were
young all of them were young another
problem with that statement of the
parent another problem with that
statement of the parent my child is too
young I don't want to scare them what
guarantees that you will live to see
them grow
up when did Allah inform you that you
will be alive to teach them when they
get
older so you think they're five they're
six they're seven I'll wait until they
turn a teenager what guarantees that
you're going to see them turn 10 years
old or 15 years old
so that is a
mistake that is a mistake so IM
concluded by saying so it is
incumbent upon the people of knowledge
especially during our
time the time that the fitna has become
widespread and the trials have become
widespread and the religion is becoming
vague and the Sunnah is becoming an
innovation notice what he's mentioning
and how long did he die how long ago did
he die about 300 years ago
IM died 1188 we are currently in
1445 currently in 1445 close to 300
years ago so he said is incumbent to
teach about the because we are in times
of FNA tribulations the religion is
becoming weak the Sunnah is becoming
Innovation he concluded by saying that
how much time do we
have they have to call it
now okay
s now as it relates to because of the
time the destruction of the
deal the destruction of
the in summary the would be killed at
the hands
of as is reported in sah Muslim on the
authority of
Abdullah that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said the will appear in
my
um and he would live for 40 days and at
the end of that Hadith the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam said then
Allah will send
Isa and he will seek the and kill him
it's also reported in sah Muslim on the
authority
of and at the end of that Hadith he
mentions that Allah will send
Isa and Isa will search for the for the
Dalal and he will find him at a place in
pal Palestine and he will kill him and
he will kill him it's also reported in
the Muslim Ahmed that the prophet
sallallahu alai wasallam
said that Isa will kill theal at the
area of lud at the entrance of that City
at the entrance of that City we will
close with the statements of sheh
when he was asked about the so I hope I
have two
minutes very important and relevant
statement by Alani and albani died
20 four years
ago died 24 years ago Alani said it is
known that Isa will descend in
dsh and he will pray behind the
Mah and this means that
is will be followed by Believers
in which is where Palestine he will be
followed by the Believers of Palestine
and the Dalal will be followed by the
Jews from
asahan y from Iran the theal will be
followed by the Jews from Iran so notice
what shik Alani is saying
Isa Isa will be supported by the
Believers and more specifically the
Believers in
Palestine and the Dalal would be
supported by the Jews from
Iran then shik albani says so this is an
indication that the Jews no longer will
control
Palestine this is an indication that the
Jews will no longer control Palestine or
the least that can be said this is sh
Alani the least that can be said is they
do not
govern then he said then
IM he said he said but the present State
of Affairs of the Muslims and he died 24
years ago does not indicate that the
Muslims are ready to follow Isa nor the
Mahi notice what he says because of the
weakness of the Muslims because of the
weakness of the Muslims what does he say
it does not indicate that the Muslims
are
ready because they are
far from the things that prepare them to
followa and and the M they are far from
that then he
says because they have not supported
Allah they have
not they have not practiced their
religion to the extent that Allah will
help them Allah says in the
Quan you help Allah Allah helps you
right meaning you obey Allah Allah will
help you so sh Alani said so they have
not done their
part they have not done their part then
sh albani
said he said so it is upon them to
return to their religion so that the
humiliation can be lifted from them as
they have been promised by their Prophet
sallallah alai
wasam so that when the Mahi
comes and when Isa
descends they will find the Muslims
ready to be
followers they will find the Muslims
followers to the might and the glory
that Allah has promised them in this
life and the
next my dear brothers and sisters may
Allah Asel guide us all may Allah
forgive us may Allah make us from
amongst those who are ready and capable
of following Isa and and the Mahi may
Allah forgive us for our shortcomings
and our faults Allah knows best
for